okay now um this is why this is a
three-month question right at this point
i need to break out and deal with these
partial fractions somehow and we've
we've shown how to do partial fractions
in a variety of ways before but this
particular one
is a technique i i don't usually do i
don't frequently do so that's why i
think it's worth me sort of spending
some time on right
rather than sort of designate okay
here's my two separate fractions and
call that like a is the co is the
numerator for one b is the numerator for
another you can do it that way if you
like but because of how simple this term
is like there's nothing much happening
on that numerator right i'm going to do
it a slightly
it's a slightly sneaky way but it
actually works out very simple for us
right what i'm going to do is just
consider i'm just going to have a an
educated stab in the dark of what
happens when i just have the simplest
version of each of these denominators on
the sorry each of these factors on the
denominators which is like so right what
will happen if they're both one and one
you can see here and this is why
difference of squares is kind of an
unusual situation that allows us to take
advantage of this symmetry i was
mentioning before right
when you put together when you sort of
like inverted commas cross multiply
right to get the common denominator you
get v t plus v on one side and then i'll
put that in brackets and then you get v
t minus v on the other
right and then this puts us on the
common denominator which we just get by
multiplying through
but hold up right you can see these v
terms are just going to cancel right
this and this
they disappear so therefore what you're
getting is 2 v t on the numerator up
there now this is great because it's
just a constant coefficient and i can
divide or multiply through by constant
coefficients on the inside so long as i
do that on the outside of the integrand
and everything is fine right
so what i would conclude is
that if this one on um vt minus a plus
one on vt plus v if that's equal to this
i actually don't want this i want it um
but smaller by a factor of 2vt so i just
need to divide through by that right so
i'm going to say here therefore
if i divide through by 1
or by 2vt rather that gives me a 1 on
the numerator a vt minus v
vt plus v on the denominator and if i
divide through the right right-hand side
here by 2vt i just have to divide this
left-hand side by 2vt so let's write it
like so divide through by 2vt and then
what you've got on the inside is these
two separate fractions right vt minus v
vt
plus v right there okay so you can see
this this here is what appears in my
integrand right so i just need to be i
just need to introduce this factor of 1
on 2vt in there so are you ready let's
do that
i'm going to have this vt squared on g
hanging out the front
and then
i can say this is from v naught to v and
i'm just doing a straight substitution
of this into this right hand side right
so this is going to be 1 on 2
v t
and if you're paying close attention to
that result we're trying to prove this
is a really good sign you'll see why in
a second
and then we get a pair of partial
fractions here one on vt minus v
one on vt plus v
or with respect to v okay
so as i mentioned before if you're
paying attention you're like oh hold on
a second this vt here will cancel with
one of the vts up here and then you've
got this two hanging out here which is
on the denominator so if you look just
let me scroll back up you're like hey
that looks familiar there's a 2g on that
denominator this you're like oh i'm
actually finally getting towards what i
wanted to and that's why this
mysteriously appears down the bottom
okay so my constant coefficient is
pretty much exactly what i need it to be
it's going to be vt one of them
cancelled all over 2g
and now we're ready to actually do the
integration okay just be a little bit
cautious let me do some highlighting
here just to make clear what's going on
um you've got this term out the front
here right now it's going to be a log
but because in the denominator you've
got a minus v it's not just a regular
log it's going to be a negative log
right
and we'll deal with absolute value signs
and why i'm about to not write them and
they don't appear in the result you're
required to prove i'll get to that in a
second
and then you've got this second term
here which is it's not so bad it's kind
of like oh that's just a regular log
term you've got a plus v there down the
bottom so i won't need to worry about
plus positives and negatives too much
okay so i'm just going to keep those i'm
going to retain those colors blue and
green so you can see me doing this all
the way through right
for starters like i like i promise
there's a negative log term hanging out
the front here and it's a v t minus v on
the inside
and then next you've got this more
more normal log term log of v t plus v
on the right hand part of this and
that's going to go from v naught to v
okay following so far
uh good thing i put that in a separate
color but let me just shove it over so
it's not
interrupting our integration there we go
that's enough space okay
so we've got that now i'm ready to
actually substitute my um
upper and lower bound but just be
cautious here because there's a lot
happening here especially with your
negative signs as well so vt on 2g
remains on the outside and then uh big
brackets here okay let's do um upper and
lower bound for the green uh
rather let's do the uh the lower bound
and the upper bound into the green and
the blue but let's just watch out for
which ones which okay because this term
here is actually positive i'm going to
put it first
so don't get confused by that here comes
log of
vt plus
v so that's it that's the upper boundary
remember it's just v being substituted
into v i usually try and avoid that but
anyway hopefully you're following along
okay
and then here comes that uh next term
which is negative log of v t minus v
okay that v there goes into that v there
all good so far
and now here comes v naught so you can
see i'm going to have to subtract
everything for this lower bound
and then i put in log of v t plus v
naught there's that substitution
and minus log of v t minus v naught
again for the end there right but you
just have to watch out for all those um
you can see there's double negatives
going on which is going to be a little
bit confusing okay so hopefully you're
following
you can see
which terms are going to be positive and
which terms are going to be negative
well if i highlight this one this one
here is positive and then this one here
will become positive because of the
double negative right so therefore in my
log terms and remember this is a result
i need to prove so i'm just going to
show this extra line of working
i'm going to have
big brackets here log of vt plus v
plus log of
t minus v zero okay so that's uh that's
going to form the numerator of my my
grand big um log term in a second so
this out the front and then what are the
negative ones right well i have minus
log of
v t minus v which i got from this green
term right here and then i'll also have
minus log of v t plus v
zero
and that's from this blue one in here
which attaches this minus sign so i'm
pretty much there i think that's a
sufficient argument to get to now the
final line will be the one that i was
asked to prove which is t equals here
comes the constant coefficient that's
just been patiently hanging out there
then the log and then all of these look
closely right these two will end up on
the numerator
so
v t plus v
v t minus v zero
all divided through
by um v t minus v
and v t plus
v zero
as required so i'll just sort of tie
that up in a neat bow
so i know some of you had trouble with
that part two there and i hope you can
see how i saw my way through that that
partial fractions trick maybe that was
the thing which you were like oh i've
not seen that done in that way before
but now you have so hopefully you have
that extra tool in your toolbox so you
just needed a refresher on it okay
now i promised that i would make a quick
comment about what's going on with
absolute value signs normally you
integrate with a log and you like log of
absolute value of whatever okay now the
reason why i haven't put absolute value
signs nor has the question in the result
that's required to prove is just think
about this scenario right this is to do
this is like forget about all of the um
calculus for a moment this is a vertical
resisted motion situation and so you're
you're dropping here and so your
velocity is always going to be positive
now that tells you a lot about where the
signs are going to go here in terms of
say for example here and here the only
thing you need to worry about is will
your terminal velocity like how does it
relate to your initial velocity
which one is larger because you can
actually as you're about to see in part
three you could pull your shoot um very
conservatively you're like i haven't
sped up very much um and so i haven't um
you know i'm going at a velocity less
than the terminal velocity so even after
i've pulled my parachute i'm still going
to keep on speeding up because i haven't
reached terminal velocity yet or
alternatively your initial velocity
might be very fast maybe you're doing
one of those halo jumps high altitude
low opening so you pick up a lot of
speed you are you have exceeded the
parachute's terminal velocity because
you haven't opened the parachute yet but
then you open the parachute and that
slows you down right so therefore
there's a relationship going on between
particularly up here this vt minus v0
this can be positive or negative
depending on whether
your initial velocity is above your
terminal velocity or not and you're
going to slow down to get down to the
terminal velocity
but whether that's positive or negative
you can see that's going to
change based on this vt minus v if you
get a negative up here um then this will
also be negative because your v at any
given time will be greater than vt so
therefore if this is negative um so will
this be and they cancel out and that's
why i'm not putting any absolute value
signs and the question doesn't either
okay um and so uh i know i've seen in
the comments some people direct message
me if you don't do it this way with a
definite integral like i said you can
you end up with a constant
of integration which you have to deal
with it's just a bit of a disaster right
it's very hard to work with and
disentangle that concept of integration
it's much easier this is one of the
reasons why the definite integral is a
great tool to have up your sleeve